islamistischer terror hass auf
homosexuelle im haus in oslo schießt ein
mann vor einem schwulenclub um sich
tötet am freitagabend zwei menschen
mindestens 21 weitere werden verletzt
der täter wurde noch am tatort
festgenommen
es handelt sich um einen norwegischen
staatsbürger mit iranischen wurzeln der
polizei bekannt ist der mann sei unter
anderem wegen körperverletzung und
drogendelikten vorbestraft der tat
verdacht lautet auf mord mordversuch und
terror und die tödlichen schüsse die
vielen am vorabend der in oslo geplanten
pride parade norwegen also unter schock
mit einem gottesdienst wird am
sonntagvormittag in oslo der opfer des
terroranschlags gedacht auch die
norwegische kronprinzessin mette-marit
zeigt ihre anteilnahme und entzündet
eine kerze kronprinz haakon muss
berichten zufolge wegen einer corona
infektion absagen
ja und dieses video soll die festnahme
unmittelbar nach dieser schrecklichen
bluttat zeigen es soll den moment zeigen
in dem der täter den tatort verlässt
passanten verfolgen den mann noch und
bringen ihn kurz danach zufall in oslo
steht jetzt unser bild kollege sebastian
bringe ja sebastian was wissen wir denn
bislang noch zu dem täter
der mann kein unbeschriebenes blatt die
liste der vorstrafen
wegen einer messerattacke auch in einem
nachtclub auch drogen sollen auf dieser
liste stehen und der norwegische
geheimdienst geben seit 2005 stehen
schon im visier gehabt und dafür
natürlich dachten wir sind natürlich
unfassbar dass erschüttert auch das
vertrauensverhältnis der norweger in
ihre sicherheitsbehörden das muss erst
wieder aufgebaut werden der mann ist im
mai von den behörden verhört worden
jetzt ist allerdings ein wir sehen im
hintergrund her das blumenmeer die
norweger sind jetzt an trotz strömendem
regen hier an den tatort gekommen um zu
trauern und auch die waadt in denen der
mann hier wahllos um wild um sich
geschossen hat haben gestern wieder
eröffnet und viele der stammgäste haben
uns erzählt wir kommen hier seit jahren
teilweise seit jahrzehnten hierher und
diesen ort weil sie unseren wohnzimmern
lassen wir uns in einem terroristen
nicht wegnehmen hier sehen sie was du
sprichst das video das die festnahme
zeigen soll erklären es einmal was genau
spielt sich da ab offenbar habe ja auch
mutige passanten dabei unterstützt den
mangel zu fassen
irgendwie gehört haben ist es
anscheinend ein glücklicher zufall
gewesen der dabei geholfen hat den mann
überwältigen es soll probleme gehabt
haben für ein automatisches gewehr mit
einem magazin nachzuladen und das haben
diese mutigen passanten bemerkt und
diesem moment ausgenutzt und ihn von
hinten gerammt und ihn festgehalten bis
die polizei eingetroffen ist ein mann
hat nicht auch auf das gewehr gestellt
damit er auch keine möglichkeit mehr hat
nach den waffen zu greifen und so haben
wir die menschen wahrscheinlich vielen
anderen das leben gerettet
sebastian bringen danke für diese
information live vor ort in oslo